CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Welcome,
everyone, to our session.
So if some people are coming
in, I know I'm
competing with lunch.
So I really appreciate you guys
made it away from lunch
early and join us here.
We are going to talk today
about how to get
content to Google TV.
And if you guys have been here
in the earlier Google TV
session, you know that there
is nothing that people love
more than getting content
on their television.
So I'm really excited
you guys are here.
And let's just say you have
a big audience for your
applications.
So that's really good.
Let me introduce myself.
I'm Christian Kurzke.
I'm a developer advocate with
the Google TV team.
And with me today
we have Andrew.
ANDREW JEON: Hi, my name
is Andrew Jeon.
I'm a platform engineering
manager at Google TV team
covering AB and general
platform features.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: And Mark.
MARK LINDNER: I'm
Mark Lindner.
I'm a tech lead on Google TV's
core applications and
frameworks.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Great.
So those are the guys who
actually make the magic happen
on the platform,
so really cool.
So hopefully by now, you've all
seen the new devices, the
new Google TV devices.
So if you haven't, go check them
out in our sandbox right
out in the second floor here.
I just want to highlight
a few things.
So this is the new-generation
devices from Sony, from Visio,
and from LG.
What they all have in common,
they are ARM-based devices.
And I'm really excited.
I know a lot of people outside
of the US have been asking us
the last year when can they
finally get their
hands on a Google TV.
And those, or at least some
of them, will be available
internationally.
So Sony has announced they're
going international.
So keep in mind, when we talk
about Google TV devices, we'll
focus on all of those devices.
And basically, the features that
we talk about today, they
are mostly available on
international or on the
ARM-based devices, and
also international.
So what I want you to keep in
mind is how people interact
with television.
And we talk a lot about content
in this session.
And it's really streaming
entertainment, streaming
movies, videos.
It's really the big thing
in the living room.
People like to be entertained
while they're on the bus,
maybe on their cell phone, but
they definitely love their
content on television at home.
There was also another session
earlier today by Osama, and he
was talking about
how to create a
beautiful user interface.
Of course, you need that, too.
And then we'll have Paul talk
about second screen.
But the centerpiece in the
living room is really content.
It's all about content,
content, content.
So what I'm going to cover or
what we are all going to cover
in this session is how do you
create beautiful content
applications for Google TV?
Some of the key features
for this is you
want streaming content.
Usually people, they want
their content on their
fingertips.
They want it now.
They want access to a huge
library of content.
How can you ensure that they get
the best quality possible?
How can you do it securely so
that you as a content owner
feel secure that content doesn't
fall into bad hands?
And how can you create a
beautiful, integrated
experience for your viewers?
So let's get started and take
a look at streaming.
So what is streaming
really all about?
And I'm sure you guys
are all developers.
You've written code.
You know what streaming is.
A lot of people, basically when
you do music streaming,
you just take an MP3
URL, you have--
[COUGH]
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Oops.
That's all right.
We'll keep you muted a little.
So the HTTP streaming of
music, it's not really
streaming in the
sense as video.
And for music, it's actually
simple because you can just
download and playback
at the same time.
You basically have enough
bandwidth on all devices
nowadays to just stream perfect
high-quality music.
For video, it's still
the bandwidth.
We're still in an age where we
don't have gigabits to every
house, although I've heard
people are working on that.
But what we really look for in
streaming video is how can we
optimize the bandwidth that
your viewers or your users
have to get the best
possible content?
And so this is just a snapshot
from one of my lab tools.
But it shows basically when
you play back video, you
always get bursts of high
bandwidth, and you basically
load, you buffer.
And in this particular scenario,
we don't really
utilize the bandwidth fully.
Because what happens is there
is a lot of times when we
don't download any data that
we actually could, so we're
not really getting
the best possible
experience to the viewer.
And so if you have too low of
a bandwidth, you're leaving
quality on the table.
On the other hand, if you have a
higher bandwidth or a higher
bit rate encoding than your
viewers have access to on
their home network connection,
then you're actually getting
this whole reloading,
re-buffering.
And let me tell you, people
hate nothing more in their
living room than looking at a
spinning reloading, reloading
in the middle of a movie.
So we want to make sure you
can do better than that.
The other thing that I want to
put out there is a lot of
people have heard about
variable bit rate.
And they're like, oh, yeah,
that's the solution.
We need variable bit rate.
Variable bit rate is OK.
It gives you the best possible
perceived encoding for your
video stream, but it's actually
still one stream.
After you're done encoding
variable bit rate stream, you
end up with one stream with
an average bit rate of--
pick one--
3 megabits, 5 megabits,
7 megabits.
But this is not adaptive at run
time to the network needs
that your viewers or
your users have.
So in an ideal world, if we
had all the computing
resources in the world, we could
encode a stream on the
fly for each network
connection.
The challenge then is the
network speed also changes.
If you watch a two-hour movie
and maybe your kids in the
back play a game or maybe your
neighbor turns on the
microwave and jams your Wi-Fi
signal, so your bandwidth
might fluctuate, even throughout
the movie.
So what you need to do is you
need to be able to actually
dynamically adapt to the
bandwidth that is available to
you while you play back.
So how can we do that?
The key word for this is
"adaptive bit rate streaming."
And it's not just variable, but
it's actually adaptive.
That means we are actually
monitoring the playback
bandwidth as we play back
the movie, and we adjust
accordingly.
So how do we do this
technically?
We don't encode the video for
each one of the viewers, for
each one of you, because that
would be a lot of encoding.
So usually we have a set
of pre-recorded,
pre-encoded bit rates.
So we have a low bit rate, a
medium bit rate, somewhere
between 5 or 10 different
quality streams.
And then we have an XML
descriptor, which
describes all this.
And then in the playback, you
basically point to the XML
descriptor.
The playback stack knows that
if the bit rate that is
currently playing, there is
potential that we could go
higher, then it switches to
the higher quality stream.
If it notices the buffer is
getting shorter and shorter,
it temporarily can switch to
a lower quality stream.
On the end, your users and your
viewers on the screen see
the best possible content that
they can with their given
network connection.
There's nothing we can do.
If they have a 2-megabit network
connection in their
home, they will see
2-megabit quality.
But I'll talk to you later how
you can actually at least
detect this on your end.
So there is various standards
for this.
So I didn't invent this.
We didn't invent this.
People have been doing this.
There is HTTP Live
Streaming, HLS.
There is MPEG-DASH.
There is smooth streaming.
And believe it or not,
there's a lot more.
Because this is cutting edge
stuff, and it's really pushing
the boundaries.
And companies who do this for a
living, they all believe or
know that they have the best
possible solution for this.
So they all tweak the standard
just a little bit and push it
a little bit one
way or another.
So we'll talk about that, too.
So in Google TV, what you can do
is our playback stack, our
media player, it actually
supports playback of adaptive
bit rate streams currently in
HTTP Live Streaming format.
So if you, for example, in your
code, you just use Media
Player and you set the data
source to be an m3u8 file,
which is the XML descriptor that
I explained, then we will
play back an adaptive
bit rate stream.
We also support LiveLine.
So that's basically
out in Google TV.
If you have one of our boxes
today, you can do this.
And now I actually want to hand
over to Andrew, and he
can tell us a little bit more
about what the engineers have
been up to recently.
ANDREW JEON: Thanks,
Christian.
So as Christian mentioned,
Android, as teamwork, has been
supporting HLS and wide-band
media format.
But as Christian mentioned,
various techniques have been
introduced by multiple
companies.
From the beginning, HLS by
Apple, Apple did a beautiful
job of coming up
with this idea.
And then later on, Microsoft
realized that
that has lots of issues.
So they extended the protocol
and then came up with
something called Smooth
Streaming protocol.
And we realized that there are a
lot of content providers who
are using Microsoft format.
And we recognized that, and we
thought it is very important
to support it from our platform
as a default without
having to do any
special thing.
So now we are announcing a
Google TV platform which
supports Smooth Streaming
protocol from the underlying
platform layer without having
to do anything from the
developer's end from that
Java application side.
So actually, from the
developer's perspective, in
order to play smooth-streaming,
encoded-streaming content,
simply create MediaPlayer, as
you can see.
Simply a MediaPlayer and then
just hand off a data source
URL, which points
to the isn URL.
Then the underlying MediaPlayer
will handle
playback gracefully.
And then later on, some content
providers got together
and realized that, oh, smooth
streaming is good, but it's a
little bit geared toward
Microsoft, as we can see.
So they come up with a standard
called MPEG-DASH, and
a lot of Hollywood studios
are supporting it.
So we are also actively working
on supporting that
from the platform layer.
But right now, we have
HLS and Wi-Fi media
format and smooth streaming.
Also, there is something
called progressive file
download, basically downloading
a file.
And as it gets buffered, you can
actually read it, and then
play back, which is not
adaptive streaming.
However, even if we keep adding
these popular streaming
protocols, we can't
actually support
everything in the world.
Because as Christian mentioned,
there are a lot of
content providers who have
legacy content in their back
end, so that it takes time
to re-encode to a certain
standard, or they are already
locked into something which we
don't support.
So there are a lot of custom
streaming servers.
So how we can solve
this problem?
So we thought about it.
And then the reason for the
people who use a custom series
streaming series protocol
is the following.
First of all, they may have a
special need, or they wanted
to add special features to
differentiate themselves from
competitors.
Or so they are so innovative,
so even though draft
specification is not really
done, but futuristic features
they adopt.
Or some of them are locked
into very old technology.
So in this case,
how can we do?
So we came up with an idea of,
let's say, if we can create an
API which can enable developers
to write their own
streaming protocol and content
processing, that would be very
nice so that we don't have to
embed thousands of streaming
protocols in our platform.
So from the API's perspective,
as we can see, MediaPlayer
interface in Android expects a
data source which is URI or
String or FileDescriptors, which
means that underlying
player implementation should
know what this means.
So in order to overcome this
limitation, we introduced
something called MediaSource
API.
So what this API does is from
the Java layer, as an Android
application developer, if you
have a custom streaming
protocol, you can just write
Java code to handle streaming,
basically getting the
data chunk from
your streaming server.
And then if you encoded this
content in a certain container
which is not standard or
something we don't support,
then you can actually extract
the data from your container
itself from the Java and then
end reserved from streaming.
And then extraction of the
audio-visual stream will be
audio element stream and
video element stream.
And then you can just push
down these two streaming
sources to the underlying
media player.
And then what's going to happen
is, although we can
delegate streaming, handling and
container parser, once an
element stream is being pushed
down to an underlying
MediaPlayer framework, it can
still use hardware-accelerated
codec and rendering and
audio-video synchronization,
And even the PTS, we
do mapping and
all kinds of stuff.
So we basically separated the
portion that developers can
adapt to their own proprietary
streaming and still use
hardware features.
So how it works is basically
we have a class in our API
package called GtvMediaPlayer,
which is a sub-class of a
Android standard video player
class interface.
And we added an API called
setMediaSource, and then it
expects a class, which is
extended from either
PullMediaSource or
PushMediaSource.
So the reason why we have two
different media sources
depends on the use case.
Let's say if you are trying to
stream live content, usually
live content is time
sensitive.
So we have to display the
content as it arrives.
It shouldn't actually delay
or buffer too much.
In that case, PushMediaSource
works better.
But in most cases of on-demand
streaming, you can keep the
buffer to keep the
quality high.
So in that case you can
use PullMediaSource.
So both PullMediaSource and
PushMediaSource inherits from
a video source interface and
then implements basic
functionalities.
And MediaSource is a support
class of those.
And then this is a skeleton
of the interface.
So as you can see, there are
multiple methods that will be
recorded by the underlying
media player to handle an
actual streaming pipeline.
So if you take a look at the
sample, for example, if you
want to implement you own
MediaSource using
PullMediaSource interface,
PullMediaSource interface
actually implements all
of this defined in the
MediaSource interface for you
for convenience, so you don't
have to do anything special.
And there are only a few APIs
you need to implement.
So, for example, here on
de-queue access unit, access
unit is a chunk of data you want
to pass down to the lower
layer media framework.
And this event is called when
the underlying video framework
display are decoded and
displayed all the content from
the buffer.
So you can keep pulling
the data and
keep it in your queue.
And then your queued data will
be de-queued by this event.
So that's very simple.
So now let's look at the
actual software.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So here's
one example application.
We were working with a company
you may have heard of--
Sirius XM.
They do satellite radio.
And they also do stream their
content over the internet
using a custom protocol because
they have very unique
needs for encoding
their media.
And initially, they came to us,
and they're like, well, we
would love to work with you,
but how do we support our
custom stream technology?
And so we worked with them and
explained the MediaSource API.
And they were actually demoing
yesterday on our devices.
And I think the quote says
it pretty fittingly.
They were really able to very
quickly develop this
application using the
new MediaSource API.
And the best part was
they did not have to
develop any native code.
They could do everything
in the Java layer,
in the Android layer.
So this was really very easy for
them to put their software
onto Google TV.
So besides all the cool stuff
that Andrew has talked about,
we also have a few new
features in general.
So the GtvMediaPlayer class,
it also supports multiple
audio tracks, so if you have
multiple languages for your
video format.
And, of course, it
supports closed
captioning and subtitle.
So we actually have time text
markup language support.
And we have also a widget that
you can customize for closed
captioning.
So here's an example
what it looks like.
And this is very basic.
This is just basically rendering
TTML on top of a
video stream.
So now you've seen it's really
easy to actually
stream to Google TV.
If you have your content encoded
in any of the common
formats like HLS or Widevine or
now also PlayReady, you can
easily do this.
If you have special needs, we
have APIs for you to implement
support for that as well.
So now the question is, how can
you make sure the viewers
really get the best
possible quality?
And how can actively monitor
what the viewers actually see?
And with that I'm going to hand
it back to Andrew, and we
can look at some of the APIs
that we came up with.
ANDREW JEON: So let's say you
can use all these APIs to
support your streaming
protocol and
your container format.
And then you use multi-thread
audio APIs to support multiple
audio tracks and
the subtitles.
And then now, you open
up a service.
So a lot of users are watching
your content.
And the next thing you are
interested in is what was the
quality the user was
experiencing?
The fact is that adaptive
streaming is relying on
fluctuating bandwidth.
So at some point in the video
playback, the playback quality
may be worse.
And at some point, it
could be better.
So how you can actually monitor
what was the actual
experience?
Let's say you have--
let's say, five tracks, so 200
kilobit, and then 500 kilobit,
and 1 Meg, 3 Meg, 7
Meg, for example.
So if a user paid for, like say,
$5 to watch this movie,
then one user was watching all
the way from the beginning to
the end using 500 kilobits.
And then the other user, who
has a relatively better
bandwidth, has been
using 1 megabit.
And then at some point in
another part of town, another
user was able to watch
with 7 megabits.
Is it fair to charge
the same amount?
So you may want to do it
slightly differently.
Or let's say a user had an issue
with the ISP, so they
couldn't watch the movie
in high quality.
So they are claiming, oh, please
give me another day.
I need to watch it again
with better quality, or
something like that.
But if you don't have a
mechanism to measure what was
actually experienced, there
will be a big issue.
So we paid attention
to this issue.
And then the biggest--
there are two things we
need to care about.
One is actual network bandwidth
during the playback,
how the network was
fluctuating.
At the same time, even if the
network is sufficient, that
doesn't mean that the user was
able to watch every video as
it's encoded and which is
supposed to be displayed.
Let's say video has been encoded
in three frames per
second, but for some reason, the
user was running something
in the background so the
hardware all slowed down, so
like half of the frame was
dropped in the middle.
So even if you have a full-blown
bandwidth for the
content, but if the device was
not capable, then actual
experience will be affected.
So once we have a set of APIs
to measure these two things,
then developers can actually
ensure customer satisfaction.
And by monitoring all the
experience, you can decide
whether to refund or extend
the playback time or do
whatever to satisfy
your customer.
And also, if the application
itself has access to this
information in real time, you
can make a good judgment.
Let's say bandwidth goes down
too much and has been dropping
too often, then you can actually
recommend the user to
view it later.
Or the bandwidth hasn't been
able to go up to full 1080p
quality for a long period of
time, then you can actually
suggest to the user, oh, you
have an issue with the 1080
playback so the user
will know rather
than they just complain.
So these are the set of APIs we
came up with so the set of
APIs can measure these things.
First of all, actual frame per
second data can be measured.
Let's say from your Java
application, you can kick off
a monitoring heartbeat to the
underlying media player.
So let's say if you want to
measure frame per second, then
the underlying media player,
along with a low-level video
SDK to measure extra frames per
second in the renderer so
that it can return the
information of how much frames
per second has been displayed
to the user.
And network bandwidth.
As the bandwidth goes down
and up and down, we can
periodically, whether every
second or something or even if
you want to monitor much
less often, then you
can do that, too.
And when the network bandwidth
changes, we can report extra
bandwidth measured right before
that point up to the
application.
And the adaptive streaming uses
buffering technology.
And buffer actually
changes in size.
Let's say at some point a 500
kilobit stream was being
played, then the buffer doesn't
have to be too long
because each chunk is smaller,
so the buffer can be this.
And if quality goes all the
way up to 1080p, then the
buffer size may get larger
to keep, let's
say, up to 10 seconds.
But even the 10-second
high-quality video requires
bigger memory.
And the buffer size and actual
fielding ratio is very
important information.
Let's say I allocate 30
megabytes and then 10
megabytes has refilled, so
that's a good indicator for
current quality for
upcoming seconds.
But if we only provide proper
size and proper filling by
bytes, there is a lot of work
for developers to do.
Because depending on the
encoding quality, you need to
calculate how many number
of seconds of
video is being buffered.
So we added another API, which
can actually return buffered
media playback duration, which
is, regardless of the size of
the buffer, regardless of the
size of encode, if you just
want to know how many seconds
of video is remaining in the
buffer, then you can actually
know that--
Two 2 remaining, 10 seconds
remaining, 0 seconds
remaining, regardless
of the size.
So we thought that would
be very useful.
And then audio information.
So right now we don't really
have a lot of use cases for
audio information because
usually audio is encoded in a
single bit rate.
But in the future, if a
developer chooses to variate
the audio encoding, let's say,
from 10 K, to 44 K, it depends
on the network bandwidth if you
want to change the audio
quality also to squeeze out
every bit of the network
that'll be possible that
you can measure.
And in the future, if a
developer wants to change on
their server side, if the
bandwidth is good enough, then
send out 7.1 channel.
If the bandwidth goes down to
a little worse than 5.1
channel, the bandwidth
is limited
then to only two channels.
So we don't really have a use
case like that today, but we
thought that would be very
useful information.
So there's an API
to return that.
Default implementation and
default set of error codes in
Android is quite limited.
So we add a bunch of extra error
codes to monitor various
error situations.
And the good thing about this
is once you start monitoring
all these variables, you can use
the Analytics framework to
send this data back to the
Google server, and you can
monitor that.
So from the encoding point of
view, there are two cases to
implement this API.
One is using existing Android
events, for example,
OnInfoListener event or
adding our own events.
So, for example, in the case
of OnInfoListener, this
example shows you how to monitor
network bandwidth
changes and frame per second
and dropped frames.
So basically, the same event
handler you usually use based
on the Android video playback
standard, so OnInfoListener
can receive the event.
And then there's an extra
what type to be defined.
For example, video info network
bandwidth or video
info FPS or dropped frames.
And you can actually create a
switch syntax to check that.
And then, in this case, what is
the type of the data in the
actualized extra value?
So, for example, in network
bandwidth, the extra will be
kilobitPS in integer.
And then the frame per
second is in integer.
So you can actually either log
it or send it to your server,
or send it to Analytics.
You can do whatever you want.
So all of this sounds good, but
if it's really difficult
to use, then that's not going
to be a good thing for
developers.
So when we release this API as
a package, we will also open
source some of the sample code
that demonstrates these APIs.
For example, we do support
smooth streaming in the
underlying media framework, but
in order to demonstrate
the power of MediaSource API,
we actually implemented
full-blown smooth streaming
protocol in Java and then used
the MediaSource API to play.
So you will have a full-blown
smooth streaming protocol
implementation in Java, then you
can defer it or change it
or whatever you want.
And along with the MediaSource
API, we support PlayReady DRM.
So if you have a PlayReady DRM
server, you can send the
license to request, receive
it, and there are certain
conventions to parse that out
and then send out the encoded
key portion back to the
underlying framework to load
the key, the session key.
So that when you send out
audio/video elements in
stream, then underlying media
framework, DRM framework will
know how to decrypt
and display.
And multi-track audio,
TTLM-based closed captioning
rendering, and extra rendering
code itself
will be open sourced.
So the sample Christian showed
you with the little red and
italic text, that code
is a sample.
It doesn't support full-blown
TTMS spec.
But if you are using a very rare
feature of a TTML, then
you can use it in your
server side.
At the same time, you can extend
the rendering widget to
handle that.
And full-blown QoS API
demonstration will be part of
the sample.
So that you can just take a look
and then use it in your
application.
OK, now I will hand it
off to Christian.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE:
Thanks, Andrew.
So I think this is
really awesome.
So basically, this is a summary
of a lot of the
features that Andrew's
team has been
working on in the platform.
And I think it's exciting for
developers who create Google
TV applications that talk to
servers to stream content to
their app and to show really
high-quality videos in their
application.
And it gives you all the
necessary APIs to monitor,
make sure the video is displayed
properly, and so on.
So actually, he already
advanced--
so wait, there's more.
So this is actually something
I want to tell you.
It's actually a session going on
right in parallel, which is
unfortunate for people
who are here live.
Fortunately, all the sessions
are recorded, so please check
it out when you have a
chance afterwards.
So YouTube has announced that
there are now content APIs.
And if you don't have servers
to host all of your content,
you can use the YouTube servers
and the YouTube
infrastructure.
And we know quite a bit about
how to stream high-quality
content, so this is really
actually pretty exciting.
So you don't need all of the
infrastructure back-end stuff.
You could just use ours, and you
can focus on creating the
app for playing back
this content.
So there is an entire session.
It's called the YouTube
Player API and the
YouTube Content API.
It's basically going on
right now as we speak.
Now we've talked about how
to get content there.
And I'm just going to talk a
little bit quickly about how
to make sure your content
actually stays secure and gets
delivered securely.
And in the interest of time,
you all know what a DRM is
supposed to do.
I just want to highlight, only
because you're streaming your
content over HTTPS does
not make it a DRM.
DRM is a lot more.
It's license management.
Here is sort of a typical use
case where, for example, a
Google TV application, it would
talk to a commerce site
where you browse through
a library of movies.
You purchase a movie.
You have all those
transactions.
And then you use Media
Player to actually
request the video stream.
The video stream comes back with
a license request, and
then you deal with a licensed
server, and
so on and so forth.
And again, just like streaming,
there's a whole set
of industry standard
protocols.
And Android, actually, in
Honeycomb, Version 3,
introduced the DRM framework,
which is really powerful.
It is extensible.
It's the standard Android DRM
framework, which, of course,
works on Google TV.
So today we do support Widevine,
which is a very
commonly used DRM system.
And actually, we have been
working on some plug-ins.
And Andrew can talk a little bit
more about the new stuff
that his team has been
working for DRM.
ANDREW JEON: So we
actually already
mentioned the PlayReady.
So it's kind of funny that we
are announcing it again here.
But it isn't Widevine, so we
added PlayReady DRM as a
default to all the
second generation
ARM-based Google TV platform.
And the way it's supported is
it's still using Android DRM
framework as is.
But if you look at the Android
DRM API, it's so powerful.
So you can almost feel like
you can do anything.
But the problem is it's
too powerful.
So it's not really well defined
for each specific DRM.
So in case of Widevine, the way
Widevine is accessed is
using the same API code, we used
to need to know the IDN
key pair to operate with the
underlying Widevine DRM.
So we took the idea of how
Widevine was supported and
then applied it to PlayReady.
So
Once we added the PlayReady
DRM in the underlying
platform, then there are certain
interactions to work
with the PlayReady.
So we came up with the
convention of ID and key pair
to send out all the parameters
to the PlayReady DRM and the
underlying platform
to operate it.
So right now it is already built
into a Google TV second
generation.
And then the picture it supports
is basic license
acquisition and license
management.
And it can be extended to
support customize licensed
software from your
application.
So let's say if you have your
own licensed server, then you
can talk to your licensed
server, basically calling the
API to request a license
request text.
And then send that off to your
licensed software, receive the
license, and then publish the
license into the underlying
framework, and then send out
video data so that video data
can be decrypted and
then played back.
And we also--
it is already there, but we
wanted to mention that even if
there's a DRM, if the DRM is
implemented in the CPU,
basically if all the DRM code
is running in the CPU, then
it's not really secure.
Because if a malicious user or
hacker can access the platform
and then gain access to the
route, then everything in the
main CPU can potentially
be accessed.
So we introduced something
called TVP, Trusted Video
Pass, which means that once the
data is decrypted, that
decrypted data cannot be
accessed by the main CPU.
The whatever software, piece
of software running in the
main CPU, will not have access
to the decrypted data.
There are various techniques--
depends on each SOC.
The chief vendor has
multiple choices.
They make their own choice and
then apply their own design.
But the data is used in the
different section of the
memory so that it
is protected.
And then once they are actually
decrypted in the
section, the way the video
pipeline works from decryption
to decoding to rendering is
done through the handle.
Let's say you've got a buffer
with encrypted data, and then
send that buffer to the
DRM security module.
Then the security module will
decrypt and keep it in the
secure zone.
And then return to the handle,
which points to that buffer,
and then hand it off
to the decoder.
Then the decoder implementation
should have
access to the secure area
to get to the data
and then decode it.
And then uncompressed data will
be also so stored in the
secure region, and then return
another handle to point to
that, and then send that handle
to the rendering piece.
So that the renderer, usually it
could be FRC in case of TP
or STMI vendor in the set-top
box case, and then send it off
to the display.
So that we can ensure
video protection.
And this feature is integrated
with smooth
streaming and Wi-Fi.
So if you are using smooth
streaming or Wi-Fi protocol or
any other custom streaming
protocol with a video-sourced
API and parity, we
will protect the
trusted video path.
So just to summarize, we have an
Android DRM framework which
enables you to access the DRM
feature from the Java
application.
And once data is decrypted and
re-protected through trusted
video paths all the way to the
display unit and then if the
device a standby device, either
a TV that supports the
HDMI input or body box that
streams in but sends out data
to HDMI out.
We always protect the data
inside of the box using the
trusted video path.
And whenever data goes in from
our external box or goes out
to the external box, we are
using HTTP content protection
to secure the content.
Now I will hand off to
Christian again.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE:
Thanks, Andrew.
Yeah.
I think this is really
exciting.
So we have now a full
set of Java APIs.
And I really want
to stress this.
There is no native
code required.
You can just stick in the
comforts of the Android
virtual machine and you can
deliver super high-quality
content, adaptive streaming.
You can even support your custom
streaming protocols.
We have support for smooth
streaming and
Widevine and HLS.
And we have a full DRM system,
which will keep your content
secure all the way end to end.
So now, how can we make
this convenient and
integrated to use?
So our vision-- and our team is
working really hard to make
Google TV sort of the user
interface to your
entertainment, to your
living room.
It's really the way how you get
to content in your living
room from both broadcast
television or satellite or
other set-top boxes that are
connected over HDMI or
streaming directly digitally
over the internet and bringing
it to the television.
So let's first look at-- and
I'll browse through this.
There was an earlier
talk where we did a
lot about user research.
So we really looked how people
find content, what they want
to watch on their television.
And usually, people, if they
know what they want, then they
search for it.
If they don't know what they
want, they just know roughly
what they're in the mood
for, they can browse.
And we have a TV
and movies app.
And then how do we
get the content?
So there is a different ways.
So one is the back end.
You may have heard that
we sort of search
stuff on the internet.
So we index videos,
site maps, and
everything on the internet.
But also on the client side, we
actually talk with devices.
And we have basically
the client side on
the Google TV box.
We talk with both physical
and also virtual devices.
So quick graphic, what
it looks like.
So basically, what we do is we
can retrieve a channel list or
a list of DVR recordings
directly from your set-top
box, if it supports it.
And we have a lot of devices
that are currently
integrated this way.
And that's how we generate
basically the TV and movies
application which aggregates
all the content that's
available from your-- in this
case-- satellite provider.
Maybe it includes also DVR
recordings that you have made.
And it also can--
I'll show later how we can
get content from the
internet into this.
And when you change channels,
then you just send the command
back to the satellite box.
So when the user searches,
this is what our search
experience looks like.
This is what our browsing
And when you pick a movie and
you want to play back a movie,
you basically get a
list of sources.
So, for example, this movie that
I picked, it may already
be on my local DVR.
It may be available from dish,
or I can get it from Amazon.
And the question that I always
get is, well, how can I get my
stuff in here?
I am the new and exciting
video provider, how
can I get in there?
And we'll talk a little
bit about that.
So just to clarify some
of the terms.
We have one-way pairing, which
is the more traditional
infrared blasting way of
talking with devices.
And then when we talk about
pairing, we talk more about
the two-way case, where we not
just change channels on a
device, but we also read
information back.
And I'm actually going to hand
over to Mark in a second, and
he can explain how we do this,
how we integrate one device.
So the use case that we're
trying to solve now is, OK,
you have Google TV at home.
You have a new device that you
bought, or as a manufacturer,
you're building a new device.
How can you integrate this
with your device?
So, Mark.
MARK LINDNER: So we're going to
talk about how do you build
your own media device.
And what a media device is is
basically it's similar to a
device driver.
It's a software component that
actually communicates with
some external device.
It's packaged as an apk, and
you can install it by
downloading it from the
Google Play store.
And a media device really
consists of three basic
components.
There's what we call the Media
Device Controller Service,
which is a standard
Android service.
And the service hosts one or
more actual media device
controllers.
There's a setup activity, which
is used to initially
pair your device
with Google TV.
And finally, there's a settings
activity in case your
device has any user configurable
options that can
be changed at any time.
So this is kind of an
overview of our
media devices framework.
We have the TV Player
Application, which
communicates with the Media
Devices Service.
And the Media Devices Service is
a standard component of the
Google TV platform.
The main job of the Media
Devices Service is to
coordinate access to media
devices, and for each session
with a media device, it
maintains the instance of the
Google TV Media Player.
So all this stuff that's in gray
is stuff that's already
implemented.
And the white portion is what
you would implement to create
a new media device.
So essentially, we have a
Media Device Controller
Service, which hosts the device
controller instance.
And that, in turn, talks
to the actual device.
So the Device Controller
Service, as we said, is a
standard Android service.
It interfaces to one or
more media devices.
The things it does is notify
the system when the device
comes online and goes offline.
It notifies the framework when
the channel is changed on the
device and so on.
It can also report information
from the device, like its
channel lineup, its list of
DVR recordings if it has
them, and so on.
So when we implement a new
Media Device Controller
Service, our framework
provides a
base class for this.
So you don't have to build
it from first principles.
We sub-class abstract device
controller service, and we
fill in some details.
The main things we
do here is we
construct our device object.
The device object, it just
basically describes the
attributes of the device's
capabilities and so on.
And we construct or
device controller
instance for that device.
So here's a simple example of
some hypothetical device with
some various options enabled.
And the final thing we can do
here is we can register a
timer to call us back at fixed
intervals so we can check for
channel updates in case our
device is the type that has a
channel in it that can
change over time.
So now the final thing we
implement is the device
controller.
This is the actual component
that talks directly to your
device through whatever
protocol that device publishes.
So one thing we do is we handle
user key press events,
like if you press channel up,
channel down, fast forward on
your remote, that gets passed
to the device controller for
processing.
And we also handle
tune requests.
So if we get one of our TV URIs
to tune to a channel or a
DVR recording or whatnot, that
gets processed as well.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Actually,
I just want to quickly
highlight one thing.
So just to make sure
you don't miss the
last part of the slide.
So basically, when you have this
device controller, you
can do tune requests to local
URLs, TV URLs, or you can go
to like HTTP URLs or other URLs
using streaming services.
So that's where basically it
ties back to the first part of
the talk where Andrew explained
how you can just use
the GtvMediaPlayer to play
back streaming media.
So the DVR can come either from
your HDMI in from your
local DVR, or it can come
through a streaming protocol
from basically anywhere
from the cloud.
So this is basically a very
elegant way to tie the
streaming together and make it
transparent, look just like a
local device connected
in your living room.
MARK LINDNER: So as we mentioned
before, the Media
Device Session holds the actual
media player instance.
So as Christian described, for a
physical device, that's just
connected to an HDMI port.
The device controller would
tell the session, yes, I
wanted to tune to HDMI port
number two, or whatever that
happens to be.
But if this is a virtual
controller that's representing
a virtual device that's
streaming media over the
internet, it would provide the
appropriate URL or data source
to the media player
as necessary.
So when we implement a device
controller, again, we provide
a subclass or a base class in
our framework, use subclass
device controller.
And the main two things you
would do here is implement
this method perform action,
which is handling things like
channel up, channel down, or
user actions from the remote,
and tune to channel where given
a channel number, we
need to tune to that channel.
So in this case, we would
translate the channel number
to an appropriate video URI for
the media player to play,
and then we would call a base
class method to notify the
framework that we want the media
player instance in that
media device session to start
playing that stream.
So in addition to those things,
the typical things you
would implement are a setup
or a pairing activity.
This is just an example of the
pairing activity from the dish
DVR integration that we have
on our existing devices.
So in this example activity, we
send a command to the DVR
saying we want to pair.
The DVR displays the
confirmation code on the video
stream, and then the user has
to enter that code to
accomplish the pairing.
And then finally, if you have
any user configurable settings
for your device, you can
implement a settings activity.
This is just a standard Android
preferences activity
that gets installed into
Google TVs settings
application.
And this is, again, an example
of DISH network's--
the DISH DVR's settings where
we can configure things like
the behavior of the fast
forward, rewind
keys, and so on.
And we can also display some
status information about our
device like the IP address
and so on.
And back to Christian.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Thank you.
Thank you, Mark.
So basically, just to summarize
this API, first of
all, if you have a device that
is connected to the Google
TV-- and connected can
be used very loosely.
It can be either an infrared
protocol that you can speak to
your device.
Maybe it's a legacy device.
Or maybe you have a more
advanced two-way
communication-capable device.
Usually they come with like
an ethernet port.
If you know how to control your
DVR device or your media
device, you can write
a Java layer code.
We call it basically a media
device APK, which is all
basically sort of like
a driver that
talks to your device.
And you can stay all in Java,
no native code required.
So you can do all this.
And then you can do this, and
you can create virtual devices
that get the content over
streaming protocols using all
of our adaptive bit rate
streaming, using all the DRM
that we have, and bring it,
integrated to the user.
And then the setup and settings
activities, they will
do device-specific things.
So if you need to negotiate an
IP address or if you need to
negotiate a pairing pin,
you can do that.
Or if you have things like for
a remote service, you might
have to log in.
If you need to set maybe a user
account and password and
so on, you can do
that as well.
So basically, what that means
is we really have one
interface to all of your content
on potentially all of
the devices in your living room
and all of the devices or
all of the content that's
out there in the cloud.
So what that means is if
you as a developer--
and I think one of the biggest
opportunities is really
creating applications that bring
content to television So
you have access to all the
content out there on streaming
protocol, so you can use HTTP
live streaming, you can use
now also smooth streaming.
And if that's not enough, you
can implement your own
streaming protocol that matches
your potentially
legacy streaming servers
or your CDNs.
We are compatible with
the industry-leading
standard DRM solutions.
We have support for Widevine
and, as Andrew pointed out,
now also for smooth streaming
and PlayReady.
We know there's a lot of
existing content out there.
And it's a huge investment for
a company to build up a
library of hundreds of
thousands of titles.
So we want to make possible that
you can adapt or create a
custom application to talk to
your existing back ends.
And all of this, even in the
Java layer, we have a DRM
trusted video path, so you can
be assured that your video is
really handled in the hardware
secure path.
So that's pretty powerful.
And then to make it easy for the
user, you can integrate,
just as a virtual or a real
media device, so users have
the exact same experience
flipping channels through
their satellite box as they
would have flipping channels
through maybe your virtual
application.
So if you're really interested
in learning more about this,
we have, of course, our
Google TV Plus page.
I encourage you to
stay in touch.
We keep it updated with
new information.
And of course, as developers,
come to our
developers.google.com/tv page.
And I just want to
thank you all.
And we take questions, so
there's two microphones.
If you have questions,
you're more than
welcome to ask us now.
Otherwise, we'll be hanging
around the sandbox throughout
the day, so you can come by
and you can play firsthand
with some of the devices and
can ask us questions.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So are there plans to bring
these features to the main
Android code base?
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Are there plans to
bring smooth streaming and the
other PlayReady features to the
main Android code base?
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Do we bring
smooth streaming to the main
Android code base?
Andrew, do you have an
answer for that?
ANDREW JEON: It actually depends
on Android team's road
map and their future
road map decision.
But we just came up with this,
so we haven't had a chance to
actually discuss when it's going
to be suitable for them
to adopt yet.
So right now, it's only
for Google TV.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
similar question,
but from the browser.
So from the Chromium browser.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So will
the streaming APIs--
or will it be possible in the
Chromium browser to use the
DRM frameworks?
ANDREW JEON: There is a draft
protocol, encryption module
protocol which is in draft and
being actively worked on.
But it will be different from
the DRM API in Android.
But there are a lot of working
groups in our company and also
other companies that have
combined, so working together,
but not available to the
general public yet.
It's actually still
in the works.
AUDIENCE: So it's the
W3C-- what is it?
The CMB--
ANDREW JEON: Yes.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So is that the
Chrome browser for Google
TV, or the Chrome browser--
ANDREW JEON: General, general.
Including all of them, yeah.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Will information from
the remote devices like
the DVRs, will it also pass
control copy information as
well once the stream
is decrypted?
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: You mean the
copy information from--
AUDIENCE: CCI.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: CCI.
The content will come in through
the HDMI channel.
I assume you mean with the
HDCP security bit?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So that is
basically just an HDMI
pass-through.
So we would just control the
playback, for example, start
the playback.
But then once the content plays
back over HDMI in, we
would just basically pass
through the device.
You guys can correct me.
ANDREW JEON: So we
don't touch CCI.
If the CCI is 1, we keep it 1.
If it's 0, we keep it 0.
And we don't do anything else.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to improve the control over
video content being displayed?
For example, the overlay or
position TV windows, or that
sort of thing?
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So overlays
and positioning the TV window
inside of an application.
It is a frequent request.
ANDREW JEON: It is actually
technically possible if you
use something called Media
Device View as an object.
But we don't really have
a concrete widget or a
component-type of infrastructure
readily
available for you to
use at this point.
But that's something we are
thinking about, but we don't
really have a concrete
timing yet.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: We know it's
a frequent request for
developers to take the live TV
or basically take the HDMI in
and embed it in their
application.
It's one of those things we
want to get it right, and
we're still working on the
proper APIs that we feel
confident we can support
going forward.
With overlays, we've seen Google
TV applications that
actually overlay over the
current screen using things
like toasts are toast widgets
with customer views and so on.
So there is Android capability
to do that.
Next question?
AUDIENCE: Any time window when
you will be releasing the
sample code?
ANDREW JEON: It will be the
later part of this year when
the device--
I mean, when our software update
for second-generation
device will be rolled
out to the market.
We are working into multiple
OEMs, so even if we are done,
it's not really readily
available to all the devices.
It takes some time.
A little bit later part
of this year.
But it will be in this year.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So basically,
all the APIs that
we talk about in this session,
they will come with the next
software update to
the ARM devices.
So today in the sandbox, it's
not quite there yet, but we're
working on basically getting the
next-generation software
update out.
And as soon as this launches, we
will have all the APIs, the
documentation, and all the stuff
on our developer page.
So stay tuned for that.
AUDIENCE: You know, we've still
got to deal with this
four-by-three--
4:3-- and 16:9, some
of the live content
which comes in 4:3.
Some of the devices, I think
I've seen one, kind of given a
button, and then you just make
it, stretch it to 16-by-9.
Is there any way we can deal
with that situation in
software or app?
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So changing
the aspect ratio
of the video input?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
4:3 to whatever--
16:9.
So press a button like normally
we in normal TVs on
the remote.
ANDREW JEON: So our platform has
an API for OEMs to be able
to implement the features to
change the aspect ratio.
So some OEMs do have a feature
to change, some OEMs don't.
But if that's critical, we can
actually strongly recommend
all of our device makers to
follow this API standard to
enable aspect ratio change.
AUDIENCE: The problem with that
is that they don't really
implement that.
My question was that is there
any way we can handle that
software, put that in our APK,
and then just tell the users,
in our own way, OK, press this
button and that would just
stretch the image?
ANDREW JEON: We will
take that as a
request, a future request.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I
didn't get that.
ANDREW JEON: We can take--
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: We'll
look into this.
We'll note it.
I think the answer
is today there
is no such API available.
But I think it's something
to look into.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I see
great demand.
And I mean, people see all the
black sides on both sides.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So I think if
you have feature requests
or any ideas, also reach out to
us on our developer page.
We have what we call an Issue
Tracker, where you can submit
ideas and things you want
to have implemented.
Or you can actually reach out to
us on our Google+ page, and
we can start a discussion
on it.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thank you.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Thank you.
All right.
I think we're just on time.
Thank you everyone very much,
and have enjoy the rest of
your Google I/O.